what are you most excited for the fans
to see when it comes to john wick 4.
oh to see
to see what this gentleman this maestro
this mad genius has
created and cooked up and given us the
opportunity to do you know we have um
some amazing john wick action and new
characters and more world building and
um it's just really been a pleasure to
work on the film and
i'm excited for people to see it see
what you're cooking up
um you know you've said that you will
keep doing these movies until your legs
give out on you so i want to know how
are your legs feeling after the fourth
one
you know chapter four was probably the
most difficult
physical film i've ever had to do
yeah but that's also what's what makes
it great
you know
chad has given me the opportunity to try
to do as much as i can
and to keep learning and to you know
keep trying stuff and to
you know i love physical acting as mr
harrison ford has said and um
i just uh
with john wick it's like the
you know who i get to work with
in
front of the camera behind the camera
it's just
top-notch best in the world well
speaking of if you get to work with so
excited that you added our canadian
actor shamir anderson to this one
fantastic good guy does a great job in
the movie i think everyone would be
happy with him fantastic guy to work
with love it you talked already about
the workout regime alone to prep for
this movie what was your favorite thing
about working with shamir
this is like the thinking stance i like
it yeah
i'm trying to think because there's like
the
you know we
we didn't really have any fight scenes
but there was uh
you know and i only had a couple of
scenes with him but
i think his his
his dedication and
his talent and also
his presentness and and his creativity
he was always there
always there always put together always
hardcore commitment
and
you know enthusiasm enthusiasm very
happy dude
i love that
anderson throws down
oh i can't see he's cooking it's good i
can't wait to see him throw down um you
know we're in vegas people like to
gamble but i want to know what is the
biggest gamble that you think you took
career-wise that really paid off
wow that was my heavy question
oh
gamble like anything that you found
online but you did it and then it paid
off
i try not to do anything where i'm like
i mean there are always
yeah you never know how a film is going
to turn out but like
what would be like
not sure what they're going to do well
gambles but i think gambles are ready to
take yeah yeah
i mean the matrix was probably
pretty crazy at the time yeah yeah
yeah
i guess
because that was a film that a lot of
people were like
you know reading the script and like
what is this
you know became so iconic well lawrence
fishburne what's like watching these two
together like what is that energy are
you kidding when we asked lawrence to be
part of number two and he's been part of
the franchise ever since it was like i
was the geek going oh my god i get to
see neil and morpheus but it was really
he's been a great collaborator as well
he was so excited
i what it was just i think he called him
and it was let's say boom it happened
like that it was super of course and he
was in and yeah it's been fun ever since
it's been a big part of our franchise
how do you describe that energy because
you know the fans love it you love it
like it's like we can't get enough of
youtube
well that's kind um true no i
listen he's one of the
he's a great artist
and he's a wonderful person
and when he comes on the set with his
creativity and who he is as an artist
it's like as he would say
swaying
and
he swings and he's
amazing that's so cool he's meant to be
in a movie theater he's a big screen
actor
guys thanks so much so excited to talk
to you thanks so much